everything I did I was following
something I really cared about everybody
said it was a crazy thing to do because
in those days nobody made it into the
film business
everybody has talent and it's just a
matter of moving around until you've
discovered what it is I can't make the
movies to make money I just make the
movies to make them good they make money
fine I don't ever see movies by myself I
always see them with other people most
people you know you don't see the
struggle part of a person's life you
only see the success they have okay
they're so smart
try this happiness is pleasure and
happiness is joy compassion is really
the secret to happiness
we didn't sort of band together we
wouldn't survive and that if one could
make it that one would help all the
others make it he's an American
filmmaker and entrepreneur he's best
known as the creator of the Star Wars
and Indiana Jones franchises as well as
being the founder of Lucasfilm as of
March 2015 George Lucas's net worth was
estimated to be five point 1 billion
dollars by Forbes magazine he's George
Lucas and here his top ten rules for
success everything I did I was following
something I really cared about something
I loved something I was passionate about
and I kept following that passion
whether it was cars whether it was
anthropology whether it was art
photography and eventually it led me to
my huge passion my real passion which
was making movies which combined all of
those things and I realized that had I
gone on to get my degree in anthropology
I would have probably made
anthropological movies in New Guinea or
someplace and eventually been on
National Geographic and you know the
History Channel and been then making
features and I had done Star Wars just
the same if I'd gone into arts center
and become an illustrator I would have
probably started doing animation and
doing animated films and making animated
things and ultimately I would have gone
on and been right where I was so no
matter which route I took because I
cared about all of them they all went to
the same place had I done what my father
had wished me to do which is to go into
these office equipment business with him
which I knew I wasn't what do I do I
knew I hated that my life would have
been unpleasant
so I think it's very important not to do
what your peers think you should do not
do what your parents think you should do
or your teachers but to do what you
inside or even your culture things but
do what's inside you I decided to go to
film school because I love the idea of
making films I love photography and
everybody said it was a crazy thing to
do because in those days nobody made it
into the film business I mean just
unless you were related to somebody
there was no way in so everything I was
silly you're never going to get a job
but I I wasn't moved by that I set the
goal of getting through film school and
just then focused on getting to that
level because I didn't you know I didn't
know where was gonna go after that I
wanted to make documentary films and
eventually I got into the goal of once I
got to school of making a film one of
the most telling things about film
schools you got a lot of students in
those days especially it's not quite so
much today but wandering around say oh I
wish I could make a movie I wish I could
make a movie you know I can't get in
this class I can't get any you know
first class I have was an animation
class it wasn't a production class I had
a history class and an animation class
and in the animation class they gave us
one minute of film to put onto the
animation camera to operate it to see
how you could move left move right make
it go up and down and it was a test to
see you know then the teacher would you
had certain requirements you had to do
you had to make it go up animator go
down and then the teacher would look at
it and say oh yes you maneuvered this
machine to do these things and I took
that one minute of film and made it into
a movie and it was a movie that one like
you know 20 or 25 Awards you know in
every Film Festival in the world and
kind of changed the whole animation
department and in meanwhile all the
other guys were and so well I wish I
could make a movie which is a production
class and so then I got into another
class and it was
really a production class but I managed
to get some film when I made a movie and
I made lots of movies while I'm in
school while everybody else are running
around saying oh I wish I could make a
movie
everybody has talent and it's just a
matter of moving around until you've
discovered what it is a talent is a
combination of something you love a
great deal that's something you can lose
yourself in something you start at 9
o'clock look up from your work and it's
10 o'clock at night and also something
that you have a talent and it did not
talent for but skills that you have a
natural ability to do very well and
usually those two things go together
I really don't read too much about what
don't you know I don't read the reviews
and I don't read what what people think
too much because I've got to really make
my movies the way I see them the way I
want them to be and then people can take
them for whatever they are they don't
like them or not like them that's their
privilege but I can't really you know I
can't make my movies for all the
influences that people around me for
better or worse want you know I can't
make it kick I can't make the movies to
make money I just make the movies to
make them good if they make money fine
you know I can't make them to make toys
you know if they find something they can
make a toy out of in the movie fine I
can't make them to be entertaining in
the way that certain critics like them
to be entertain you know these the Star
Wars especially have been created in a
very particular style and I've tried to
be faithful to that style and somebody
just like that style is fine it's funny
that the one thing I did here on the
last film that came out was something
they discovered that it was a film for
young people and that was a big
complaint why did they make it might
waiting to make a children's film
assembly on they've all been that way
either you ever saw the other ones but
been that way forever but everybody grew
up and they
that we're going to now see Terminator 5
making that kind of movie I think one of
the reasons that Steven and I have been
as successful as we have is because we
like the movies we'd like to go to the
movies we enjoy movies and we want to
make movies like the ones we enjoy we
want to be able to entertain the
audience we weren't able to startle the
audience we're going to be able to blow
the audience away and say have them walk
out in theatres saying well that was
fantastic I was really moved by that
that's where the part of the fun of it
is and you know you you want people to
think you want people to be emotionally
moved and there's a theory behind that
in terms of storytelling it's been
around for thousands of years and that's
where something like live theater or
live performance is something that is
very valuable because you get instant
feedback from hear from the audience and
you kind of know the things that work
and the things that don't work that's
the advantage that you know the Greek
storytellers had and Shakespeare had
that us in the film industry are harder
to come by which is you know to be able
to see it a see an audience reaction and
adjust to what works so you have to use
your experience of sitting through a lot
of movies I don't ever see movies by
myself I always see them with other
people because I want to know what works
I want to know where they laugh I don't
know where they don't laugh I want to
know what they think about it afterwards
because in the end that's that's the art
that I'm working with is is you know
trying to communicate in a way that is
effective and and people react to no
matter how easy it looks on the outside
it is a very very difficult struggle
most people you know you don't see the
struggle part of a person's life you
only see the success they have but I
haven't met anybody here at the Academy
or anywhere else that hasn't been able
to describe years and years and years a
very very difficult struggle through the
whole
process of achieving anything whatsoever
so and there's no way to to get around
that and the secret is just not to give
up hope it's very hard not to because if
you're really doing something worthwhile
I think I think you will be pushed to
the brink of hopelessness before you
come through the other side
and use about to hang in through that
well I think ultimately we don't have to
be mean you know we're not really that
competitive I came out of film school
with a lot of friends we all helped each
other we helped each others in our
careers and we just never were
competitive about anything we were
always competitive in a friendly way to
say you know like playing cards or you
know dunking baskets to say okay you're
so smart try this you know and so it's
that kind of competition not the you
know you must be destroyed and and you
must fail so I can win and all that sort
of thing happiness is pleasure and
happiness is joy you know can be either
one you add them up in exotic Falls on
the uber category of happiness pleasure
is short-lived lasts an hour last a
minute lasts a month and it Peaks and
then goes down it Peaks very high but
the next time you want to get that same
peak you have to do it twice as much
it's like drugs you know just you have
to keep doing it because it insulates
itself no matter what it is whether
you're shopping whether you're you know
engaged in any other kind of pleasure
it all has the same quality about it on
the other hand is joy and joy is the
thing that doesn't go as high as
pleasure in terms of your emotional
reaction but it stays with you joy it's
something you can recall pleasure you
can't so the secret is that even though
it's not as intense as the pleasure the
joy will last you a lot longer and
people who get the pleasure they keep
saying well if I can just get richer and
get more cars
I'll never you'll never relive the
moment you got your first car that's it
that's the highest peak yes you can get
three Ferraris and a new Gulfstream jet
and maybe you'll get close but you have
to keep going and eventually you run out
I mean you just can't do it doesn't work
so if you're trying to sustain that
level of peak pleasure you're doomed
it's a very American idea but it just
can't happen you just let it go
peak great pleasure it's fun it's great
but you can't keep it going forever just
accept the fact that it's hearings gone
and maybe again it'll come back and
you'll get to do it again joy lasts
forever
pleasure is purely self-centered it's
all about your pleasure it's about you
it's about it's a selfish self-centered
emotion that's created by a
self-centered motive of greed joy is
compassion joy is giving yourself to
somebody else or something else and it's
a kind of thing that is in its subtlety
and lowness much more powerful than
pleasure you get hung up on pleasure
you're doomed if you pursue joy you will
find everlasting happiness children
teach the most important thing of all
which is compassion and compassion is
really the secret to happiness and the
secret to a good life and it's a hard
thing to learn it's hard to learn not to
think about yourself and I think about
somebody else but we have a little baby
it becomes pretty easy if you're open to
it and any parent that is reasonably
normal and opened these sorts of things
really does learn compassion caring
about another person through having kids
and putting that that other person first
I gets the advantage that that my
generation had is when we were in film
school and we're starting the film
business the door was absolutely locked
and it was a very very high wall and
nobody got in there for all of us
beggars and scroungers down the front
gate decided that if we didn't sort of
band together we wouldn't
five and that if one could make it that
one would help all the others make it
and we would continue to help each other
so we banded together I mean that's
that's how Katelyn figured it out any
society starts that way any society
begins by realizing them together by
helping each other you can survive
better than if you fight each other and
compete with each other if I got a job I
would help somebody else get a job if
somebody got more successful in me it
was partly my success I wasn't my
success wasn't based on how I could push
down everybody that was around me my
success was based on how much I could
push everybody up and eventually their
success was the same way and in the
process they pushed me up and I pushed
them up and we kept doing that and we
still do that and even though we all
have in essence competing companies we
see it as if everybody succeeds or my
friends succeeds that everybody succeeds
so that that and that's the key to it is
to have everybody succeed not to gloat
over somebody else's failure
one of the basic motifs of fairytales is
that you find the poor unfortunate on
the side of the road and when they beg
for help if you give it to them you end
up succeeding if you don't give it to
them you end up being turned into a frog
or something so it's something that's
been around for thousands of years a
concept that's been around for thousands
of years
and it is even more necessary today when
people are much more into their own in
grand iseman than they are in helping
other people I mean the one thing about
you here at the Academy here is
constantly about public service about
helping others I don't think as anybody
who's become successful that doesn't
understand how important it is to be
part of the larger community to help
other people in larger community to give
back to the community and it's not
something you do you start doing when
you've made it now I'm on the top I can
sort of enhance my joy and and
self-esteem by helping the poor
underlings it's when you are at the very
lowest level and you're struggling when
we were in film school we were all very
very poor we were all very very
struggling we all need
jobs very desperately and if one of us
couldn't get a particular job we'd send
another friend in on the interview
because we were hoping that one of us
would get the job and so you do it right
from the very beginning you can start
every single day you know whether it's
helping your brother or sister or
helping your peers at school or helping
in the community but it's not just it's
not just a kind of public service thing
it's a way of life if America is the
pursuit of happiness the best way to
pursue happiness is to help other people
because there's nothing else that will
make you happy you can be as rich and
famous and powerful as you want to be
and it will not bring you happiness and
that's said over and over and over again
in such a cliche that it hardly goes
anarta needs to be said but people don't
understand that it's actually true and
you can find people rich powerful and
famous and they aren't happy and you can
find people who have discovered the fact
that it's really helping people it's
really being compassionate or other
human beings that makes you happy
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Kevlar blast shield
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of George Lucas's top ten
rules meant the most of you leaving the
comments I'll join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
if there is one thing that you would
like to be remembered for one project
that you have done or that you have yet
to do what what would it be raising my
kids there you go that's a human being
right there folks learning to make films
is very easy learning what to make films
about is very hard and what you really
got to do is focus on learning as much
about life and about various aspects of
it first and then learn just the
techniques of making a movie because
that's stuff you can pick up pretty
quickly but having a really good
understanding of history literature
psychology sciences are very very
important to actually being able to to
make movies for all of my friends who
are successful all the same age I want
school together all had fun the secret
ingredient which everything why you guys
so successes we all love movies we
aren't doing it to get rich we never
thought we were ever going to get rich
or be successful or anybody would even
like it but we love movies and we make
the kind of movies that we'd love to see
oh I'd like to see that and we have the
advantage of being able actually make
the movie you know say okay well it's
not coming out so let's just make it
when I play it out